the reason number one I can tell my life
is preposterous
I've seen this guy more than I've seen
some of my friends in the last right
it's it's preposterous so you both get
to work on a lot of different projects
and you get you you're both very in
demand actors what was it about this
script that said I have to do this well
for me I feel like first of all working
with noah was really exciting because
i've admired what he's done so much on
Fargo and Legion and to get to be part
of his first film was really exciting
and then of course with John and Zazi
and Ellen Burstyn Porsche Prime it was
really an exciting group of people to
work with but then also I feel like the
character it's very unusual to get to
play a woman who is facing an
existential crisis like I hadn't had
that opportunity before and I think it's
a really interesting thing to get into
yeah you know when you when you look at
the sort of how these things coalesce
and and how the package comes together
so to speak and and this one is involved
and then Noah's involved in Noah's
rewrites the script in the script gets
100 percent better and then Ozzy comes
onboard and Ellen Burstyn and all these
you could go well this seems like it
seems like a great room to be in I
wouldn't mind to be part of this room
and and I also just like the story I
liked how it was a non-traditional take
on a person going through something that
they're having a very hard time
describing and having a very hard time
relating because they're because by
nature of what they're going through
there just aren't that many people that
have anything to relate to it and and I
think that that that was a you know kind
of setting against the backdrop of this
well-known kind of tabloid story is one
thing but really looking into the person
behind that I thought was was actually
kind of sweet in a way and sort of like
giving this person their
the ability to tell their story I was
gonna say that one of the things I
thought was very cool and unique is the
way that the aspect ratios changed with
her sort of mental state or talked a
little bit about how early on did you
know about that no one wanted to do
these changing aspect ratios and what
was your reaction seeing it well Noah
described his idea to me when we were
preparing for the movie that it would
kind of reflect that mental state of
like the Wonder and magic of seeing the
galaxy as a as an astronaut and then of
course the kind of like more humdrum you
know watching the ceiling fan back to
earth moment and how the world kind of
opens and you know expands and contracts
I guess based on on that and it's always
fun to have directors experiment and I
love being part of that there were a lot
more I think that we didn't use that we
had
yeah just stuff twisting around and a
lot of a lot of a lot of practical
effects that that yeah even like
vertical I remember they shot like
completely vertical so that he was he
was definitely going for something in it
and it works I think I think the first
time you see it when when the the
beginning of the film and squeezes down
and you feel like it does feel kind of
claustrophobic you like oh wow we're
back on earth yeah well the thing is
like a lot of people don't realize I
think when you do like a long one or or
you do certain tricks that you know it
really can help shape your mental the
average person I don't think realizes
what's going on but they feel it right
exactly you know yeah the first time I
think people when you explain it to them
they go oh that's why I felt so like
anxious or whatever and you're like yeah
that's because we're used to like quick
cuts and being sort of told a story in
that way and when it's when it's left to
unfold and very long takes and things
like that people generally really get
kind of like what's going on what's
gonna
Bliley speaking of cool takes there's
one in the hospital
of you going through and it it's awesome
to talk a little bit about filming that
one yeah it was um this sort of again
Noah wanting to create this sort of
feeling of I think like almost the earth
moving under your feet you know when she
finds out that something happens to
someone she cares about a lot I won't
spoil it hopefully but it's almost like
the the rugs being pulled out from under
her and she's just kind of like
transported into another space and yeah
it was a very intense shot that they
kind of attached me to this okay rolls
me through space yeah it comes across
really cool on screen how long did it
take to shoot oh it was you know like a
few hours well that's not no okay yeah
um before I run out of time with the two
of you I have to ask we you aware I
didn't I spoke to you on the red carpet
of Good Omens and I brought up Top Gun
and and the thing you said went like
everywhere are you aware of the level of
interest in that project yeah I mean
it's it's a there's a reason that
they've waited 30 years to make any kind
of sequel or continuation of that story
is because they wanted to get it right
because they've realized that it's a
wildly popular thing and it's a you look
at the 85 version now and you think how
do they how do they even do it back then
because it's it's and hearing the story
is on how they actually did it I was
like there's no way they but now they
can make you know we got cameras that
you can put you know everywhere now so
it's it's the level of technology that
they've that that including like
brand-new stuff is is pretty is pretty
eye-opening this my last thing for you
people are genuinely myself included so
effing excited for you to be in the next
Thor thank you um can you what can you
have you read anything what can you
tease and how excited are you to come
back
only read the comics but it's which I
think a lot of fans have also read so I
probably know about as much as you do
right now or you know Thor fans yeah
sure I'll leave it there and just say
congrats on the movie wish you guys
nothing but the best